let's get reaction to all of this news
involving Russia the latest on the
investigation also surrounding Russia
here in the u.s. from Senate Judiciary
Committee Chairman Chuck Grassley and
committee member Senator Lindsey Graham
I sat down with them this afternoon
in the Judiciary Committee hearing room
on Capitol Hill and started by asking
about the administration's new sanctions
against Russia well I'm glad to know
that it's happening and secondly because
of the 2016 2016 election very good
reason for doing it but there's plenty
of reasons for doing it otherwise all
you got to think about is Ukraine and
their interference and the Baltics
Georgia and Crimea in all that they're
trying to recreate a Soviet state and we
got to put a stop to it I can't say much
better as 98 to 2 vote by the Senate we
can't agree on much of anything in the
Senate but 98 senators voted for these
sanctions and up until today really they
had not been implemented by the
administration clearly the assassination
in Great Britain had an effect here this
was a nerve agent associated with the
Russian military clearly Russia was
involved here so I'm very pleased but we
need to do more you on the committee
have released a series of letters today
calling for a special Council another
special council why I would like to
suggest to you that you use the word
special consul yes because of what it is
but we're thinking in terms of a special
council to work with the inspector
general we have all kinds of confidence
in the Inspector General's work we know
he's a good person we know he's doing
good work digs in deep he's got a staff
of maybe about 400 but he doesn't have
the capability of working with people
that have left the Justice Department he
can only bring in those people that are
already in government to investigate and
this special consul working in a team
and I want to emphasize the word team
with the Inspector General we'll give
him the tools he needs to get all the
information that we're asking to get and
we sent him 30 questions that we
want investigators I mean there's a lot
of questions in here I mean are you
seeing things that are really red flags
for you that you've seen that that are
not getting answered number one chairman
Grassley has done a very good job of
looking at all things Russia we've had
hearings in our committee about how
Russia operates we've brought in Sally
Yates and and clapper and a bunch of
other people who are worried about the
Trump campaign association with the
Russians we haven't found any evidence
collusion but Muller is doing his job
the Chairman and I have looked real
close at the FBI investigation of the
Clinton email scandal and I've come way
believing that it was shockingly done
that there were conflicts of interest
that there was political bias that may
have resulted in giving Clinton to pass
the steel dossier was paid for by the
Democratic Party diffusion GPS mr.
Steele had associates in Russia that
could have easily compromised him and we
believe the FISA warrant process was
abused and the reason we want a special
counsel is I think crimes may have been
committed mr. Steele was sued in May of
2017 in Great Britain for libel somebody
mentioned in the dossier sued him in
British Court and in the response to the
lawsuit he admitted in British Court
that he had talked to media outlets in
September of 2016
about the dossier the FBI told the FISA
Court all through 2016
September October in November that mr.
Steele had no contacts at all with the
media when it comes to shopping around
the dossier so we have a filing in
British Court where a lawyer from mr.
Steele admits to talking to the American
media worldwide media in September at
the same time of 2016 the FBI was using
him as a confidential informant somebody
needs to look and see whether or not who
he's lying to we'll give him the tools
to do it because they cannot be counted
on to investigate themselves I mean it's
kind of common sense if you do something
wrong you don't have
Fox garden the chicken house so what are
we investigating here the number four
person Department of Justice Bruce ORS
wife worked for fusion GPS he had dozens
of contacts with mr. steel the informant
the FBI was using on the payroll of the
Democratic Party there's no way in the
world he should have interactive with
mr. steel cause his wife worked for the
same organization so somebody other than
the people in charge today needs to look
at what they did yesterday do you think
Andrew McCabe should be fired before he
retires
I don't not sure I want to make that
judgment right now I think it could
happen but I know I have great respect
for OPR the Office of Professional
Responsibility and they have found
something grossly wrong but I'm not
going to draw a line on what should be
done about it
something could it could happen but you
know we've raised enough questions about
him over a long period of time and I
suggested to certain people they oughta
been fired
just soon as we got a new Attorney
General well the the punishment for
violating the law should be you lose
your job if the in fact did authorize
FBI agents to talk to the media and lied
about and seeing what you've seen you
think you did well I don't know we'll
leave that up here's what I do know that
the FBI and the Department of Justice
were corrupt in my view when it came to
handling the email investigation of
Clinton and the entire FISA warrant
application process was abused and one
last thing
not one Democrat seems to care about
this why did we start out with this the
Trump Russia was the start of it but you
follow the facts and the facts led us to
that there's a lot of things done in the
previous administration so today I was
criticized in my committee by Democrats
that why are we interested in in the
previous administration well if there's
political interference in the Justice
Department the FBI in one administration
and that's what we were looking into
wouldn't it be natural that it's wrong
in the previous administration the
president said today that stories about
a major shake-up in his administration
are wrong
are overwritten but clearly he's
considering some additional changes
including what has already happened with
Rex Tillerson if he did fire jeff
Sessions how would that go over in the
Judiciary Committee I would only answer
your question this way unless you push
me on it I don't think he should be
fired I'll push you on it what do you
think would happen they'd blow up the
committee the chairman has done a
wonderful job getting nominees out of
the committee with a lot of obstruction
but if you had to replace the Attorney
General Jeff Sessions was somebody knew
it would blow the place up it'd be seen
as an effort to undermine the momentum
investigation it locked the Senate down
and I need Jeff Sessions done a good job
have you've heard Lance have you read
plans to do that I have people in
journalism like you asking us that and I
gave the same answer to you but remember
this administration's got enough to do
there's a hundred vacancies in the court
now that my committee has to deal with
well we don't have time to deal with a
lot of things that are going fairly
smoothly but one last thing about what
brought us here today if the shoe were
on the other foot can you imagine how
the media would be reacting that if you
found that the lead investigator of an
investigation had a political bias
against Clinton and for Trump that if
there was a dossier used by the FBI to
get a FISA warrant and the Republican
Party paid a foreign agent go to Russia
to get information on Hillary Clinton
how they would be behaving today all I
can say to my Democratic colleagues I
have supported Muller having the
independence to do this job but if you
don't think it's wrong for the FBI to
use a paid political informant and
present court a dossier that's been
unverified then I disagree so the bottom
line here folks is that what the FBI and
the DOJ did in terms of investigating
Clinton and the initial investigation
regarding the Trump campaign really
bothers me and I want somebody other
than a politician looking at it chances
that you get a special counsel in
addition to what's already there
we'll be shocked if somebody doesn't see
the inherent conflict in the Department
of Justice regarding investigating
itself high probability I'm going to use
as much leverage as I can and I think I
have a lot to get the job done
senators we appreciate the time thank
you okay thanks